the Air Force has just joined the pride
Coalition tweeted out June is pride
month the department of the Air Force
proudly recognizes and celebrates
generations of
lgbtqi positive service members and
their contributions to the Air Force and
space force and the image is a
silhouette of an Airman
saluting in front of the pride flag so
because it's a silhouette you don't know
which way he's facing if you look at his
art looks like it's his right arm so it
looks like he's saluting out away from
the pride flag I suppose you could you
could also see it as the Airmen
saluting the pride flag either way it's
basically the same effect the rainbow
flag is our new Imperial flag